the most um something happened the other
day after we caught up Liz oh just made
your fans go for Cirque gosh I love this
I was collaborate with her on the lights
for this interview yes I got a collab so
now that Brooklyn to do is it a done
deal
do you need a broker swear something
girl that's a hustler move if you did
right I mean I would not like to but I
would have to respect it Lizza was a
beach there and she's actually like
validating that with him women and
making them feel confident which is
everything I stand for so I admire her a
lot free Rica Georgie Vaughn she was
everything we wanted to be last night at
a 58 hole diamond ball which raised over
five million dollars for her Clara
Lionel Foundation what are you most
proud of accomplishing with your charity
I'm really proud of the fact that people
come back year after year I'm also
really proud of the fact that you have a
lot of newcomers every year for them to
give their heart their gifts it means a
lot
finally you've given your fans little
golden eggs are you hinting to everyone
that you're gonna be the new poison ivy
and Batman oh that's yeah no that has
nothing to do a poison ivy here that has
to do a lot with Batman I have separate
obsessions have a bigger obsession with
poison ivy so now you need to do it on
the big screen I mean why not yeah if
it's not me it has to be you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]